we have to experience the pain of  avoiding  something build that up enough which  then motivates us to  all right now the pain avoiding this or  not doing this  is greater than the pain the risk of  just doing the damn thing  and i think that's a phase of learning i  don't think that phase ever goes away  but  i think the more we do that the less  time we have to spend  building up the pain to motivate us to  go in the direction of our truth so  maybe when we're 10 we have to build the  pain up to a level hundred like all  right now i'll  like be myself at school instead of like  acting the way everybody wants then  maybe by the time we're 20 maybe we're  only building it up to 90 then  30 we're okay we're making progress now  we only have to build it up to 75  then we're 40. then maybe we only have  to build up the pain of avoidance to  like  50. that's painful but relief comes the  quicker and the more fiercely  i face the thing that i'm afraid of